Uh, for those people that are still haven't gone out and voted,
I want to know why, really.
I mean, put it in the comments why you're not voting.
The local elections are absolutely pivotal
in giving us a test
of what the general election is going to look like
and sending a clear message out to the mainstream parties that the,
that basically we don't believe them.
Uh, the local elections are about electing local councillors
that know the communities,
that support the communities,
are the voice of the community,
are not just there just to take a simple salary and
and concourse fabricated lies about everybody else.
Now, one of the things that I say when it comes to elections
is that if you want to be heard
and you want your voice and,
and your concerns to be counted,
then you must use your, must use your vote as an actual voice and.
And simply since you got home and morning and good morning.
It's not good enough. And another thing that's not good enough
is the fact that the people are saying, well,
she's a good person, he's a good person,
and they believe that we have a democratic right
and they believe in human rights
violations are happening in Gaza and Kashmir,
but they happen to be Labour,
Conservative, Liberal Democrats and the greens.
Well, that's not right really,
is it? I mean,
you either either are complicit in genocide or you're not.
You either
Funding those countries who are using arms to kill children and women.
Or you're not. And if you are a member of an organization
or a party that complicitly does that,
then you're not a very good person,
are you?
So those people that believe that they can vote for these candidates
are a part these mainstream parties,
whether they red, blue,
yellow or green, and are good people?
Well, they're not,
are they? So let's get out there and let's make that difference.
You need to be voting for Workers Party candidates.
And where they're not,
there are lots of independents up and down the country.
Uh, check them out.
Make sure that they, they are responsible people and they are standing.
Uh, what you believe in?
And that is that we must stop these atrocities across the world.
We must stop using profit and personal gain, uh,
to kill people.
And what we must do is get ready for the general election.
So please, if you haven't voted,
if you got a friend or a neighbour or a relative that hasn't voted,
encourage them to go out and vote
and make sure that they use their vote responsibly. Thank you.